- Selamat datang kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous dan
saya adalah pengarah teknikal untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran keenam siri ini dan ia adalah pelajaran kedua dalam
unit kedua siri, yang berkaitan dengan algoritma kuantum.
Dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, kita bincangkan model pertanyaan
pengiraan, dan kita nampak bahawa dalam model itu, algoritma kuantum boleh
memberi kelebihan yang ketara
berbanding algoritma klasik, termasuk kelebihan eksponen dalam kes masalah Simon.
Malangnya, model pertanyaan tidak benar-benar mempunyai sebarang relevansi
praktikal yang langsung atau segera.
Konsep kotak hitam adalah abstraksi yang sangat berguna seperti yang ternyata, tapi kita ada kerja untuk
dilakukan kalau kita nak menggunakan
pandangan-pandangan yang kita dah
perolehi dari model pertanyaan kepada tetapan pengiraan yang lebih standard di mana input diberikan sebagai rentetan bit
dan bukannya sebagai oracle atau kotak hitam.
Tujuan utama pelajaran ini adalah untuk mewujudkan asas
dari mana kita boleh melakukan itu.
Ini adalah gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran. Untuk sebahagian besar pelajaran, kita akan fokus
pada kos pengiraan,
atau dengan kata lain, seberapa sukar tugas pengiraan yang berbeza dan cara kita boleh mengukur kesukaran itu.
Secara kasarnya, ini diterjemahkan kepada berapa lama kita perlu menunggu
untuk pengiraan selesai dan akhirnya masalah pengiraan mana
yang boleh kita selesaikan dan mana
yang di luar kemampuan kita.
Kita akan mulakan dengan
beberapa contoh. Pemfaktoran integer dan mengira pembahagi sepunya terbesar
atau GCD untuk singkatnya.
Ini adalah contoh-contoh yang sangat baik untuk menggambarkan prinsip-prinsip asas, dan ia juga kebetulannya
sangat relevan dengan algoritma Shor, yang akan kita
bincangkan dalam pelajaran seterusnya,
jadi kita akan berkesan
mendapat manfaat berganda dari contoh-contoh ini.
Kemudian kita akan bincangkan konsep kos pengiraan dengan lebih umum dan cara kita boleh mengukurnya.
Ada banyak cara berbeza
yang boleh dilakukan, tapi kita akan fokus dengan agak sempit pada cara kita boleh melakukan ini dengan model circuit pengiraan,
khususnya Boolean circuit
dan quantum circuit.
Fokus di sini akan pada algoritma berbanding perkakasan komputer, sebagai contoh, dan kita akan lebih prihatin
dengan cara kos
menjalankan algoritma berskala apabila kejadian masalah tertentu yang dijalankan membesar dalam saiz berbanding dengan berapa saat,
minit, atau jam sesuatu
pengiraan tertentu memerlukan.
Idea yang mendorong sudut pandang ini adalah bahawa algoritma mempunyai
kepentingan asas.
Sampai hari ini, kita
masih menjalankan algoritma yang dibangunkan
masa yang sangat, sangat lama dahulu dan secara sangat semula jadi, ia akan digunakan
terhadap kejadian masalah yang semakin
besar menggunakan perkakasan yang lebih pantas dan lebih boleh dipercayai apabila teknologi berkembang.
Dan cara ia berskala memberitahu kita banyak
tentang seberapa berguna ia dan seberapa berguna ia akan terus menjadi.
Dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan beralih kepada tugas yang sangat penting, iaitu menjalankan pengiraan klasik
pada komputer kuantum. Sebab ini penting bukan kerana kita berharap untuk menggantikan komputer klasik
dengan komputer kuantum,
yang nampaknya sangat tidak mungkin berlaku dalam masa terdekat jika ia pernah berlaku, tapi sebaliknya kerana ia membuka
banyak kemungkinan menarik
untuk algoritma kuantum.
Khususnya, setelah kita tahu cara menjalankan pengiraan klasik
pada komputer kuantum, ia menjadi tersedia untuk algoritma kuantum sebagai subrutin
jadi kita boleh berkesan
memanfaatkan semua yang kita tahu tentang algoritma klasik dalam usaha kelebihan pengiraan kuantum.
Komputer klasik yang kita ada hari ini adalah benar-benar keajaiban teknologi.
Ia sangat pantas, tapi ia tidak begitu pantas sehingga tiada masalah pengiraan
yang di luar kemampuannya.
Sesetengah masalah pengiraan
sangat sukar secara semula jadi sehingga walaupun kita memang ada
algoritma untuk menyelesaikannya, tiada komputer di planet Bumi hari ini
yang cukup pantas untuk menjalankan algoritma-algoritma ini hingga selesai walaupun pada input bersaiz sederhana dalam tempoh hayat manusia
atau bahkan dalam tempoh hayat
Bumi itu sendiri.
Untuk menerangkan lebih lanjut, jom tengok masalah
pemfaktoran integer.
Pernyataan masalah adalah sangat mudah. Input kepada masalah adalah integer N yang sekurang-kurangnya dua, dan outputnya adalah pemfaktoran perdana N,
dan apa yang itu bermaksud adalah senarai faktor nombor perdana N bersama-sama dengan kuasa yang nombor-nombor perdana ini mesti dinaikkan
untuk mendapatkan N dengan
mendarab semuanya bersama-sama.
Sudah tentu, kita sentiasa boleh mendarab faktor-faktor perdana bersama-sama dalam mana-mana urutan, tapi selain dari urutannya,
pemfaktoran perdana adalah sentiasa unik untuk setiap pilihan N.
Fakta itu dipanggil teorem asas aritmetik, dan kalau kamu berminat
untuk mengetahui lebih lanjut tentangnya, ia adalah sesuatu yang boleh kamu jumpai
di bahagian paling awal
banyak buku tentang teori nombor.
Sebagai contoh yang sangat mudah, ini adalah pemfaktoran perdana
nombor 12.
Ia adalah dua kepada kuasa dua
kali tiga kepada kuasa satu.
WEBVTT
Tidak mengejutkan, komputer boleh memberitahu kamu ini dalam sekelip mata dengan hanya mencari
faktor perdana secara berulang.
Ini adalah satu lagi contoh. Saya tidak akan cuba membaca nombor ini.
Ia adalah kira-kira 3.4 quattuordecillion, dan saya terpaksa mengakui bahawa saya rasa pelik bahawa ada nama sedemikian,
tapi bagaimanapun, ia mempunyai 46 digit perpuluhan dan di sini kamu boleh lihat
pemfaktoran perdananya.
Komputer juga boleh memberitahu kamu ini. Saya memfaktorkan nombor ini menggunakan kaedah pemfaktoran yang termasuk dalam perpustakaan matematik simbolik untuk Python,
dan ia mengambil masa beberapa saat, yang bukan tempoh yang sangat lama, tapi ada kelewatan yang ketara.
Dan sudah tentu kaedah factor N tidak menemui pemfaktoran perdana ini dengan mencari faktor perdana secara naif.
Ia sebenarnya menggunakan gabungan
algoritma yang berbeza termasuk satu yang dipanggil algoritma baris berwarna, yang merupakan algoritma untuk pemfaktoran
yang lebih canggih daripada mencari faktor perdana secara iteratif secara naif, dan walaupun itu mungkin kelihatan
seperti nombor yang agak besar,
sebagai input kepada masalah pengiraan, ia sebenarnya tidak besar langsung.
Ia hanya 46 aksara.
Ini adalah satu lagi contoh. Ia adalah nombor dengan 309 digit perpuluhan.
Kalau kita tulis dalam notasi binari, ia mempunyai 1,024 bit dan itulah
kenapa ia dipanggil RSA1024.
Pemfaktoran perdana nombor ini tidak diketahui pada masa ini.
Nombor ini datang dari
cabaran pemfaktoran RSA, yang dijalankan oleh RSA
Laboratories dari 1991 hingga 2007.
Mereka menawarkan hadiah wang tunai
untuk pemfaktoran perdana pelbagai nombor yang semakin
besar, termasuk yang ini, yang bernilai $100,000 US,
tapi hadiah itu tidak pernah dituntut.
Keselamatan sistem kripto kunci awam RSA adalah berdasarkan kesukaran
pemfaktoran integer.
Kalau kamu boleh memfaktorkan, kamu
boleh pecahkan sistem, dan jadi tujuan cabaran itu pada dasarnya adalah untuk menjejaki
keadaan seni dalam pemfaktoran.
Kesimpulannya adalah bahawa
memfaktorkan nombor ini adalah di luar kemampuan kita sekarang.
Setakat yang kita tahu, masalah itu sendiri terlalu rumit untuk komputer klasik
selesaikan dalam amalan.
Nombor cabaran RSA terbesar yang telah difaktorkan setakat ini, by the way, mempunyai 250 digit perpuluhan.
Mungkin agak susah
untuk membaca ini pada skrin, tapi inilah pemfaktoran perdana RSA250.
Ia dilakukan pada tahun 2020 menggunakan algoritma yang dikenali sebagai penapis medan nombor, dan ia adalah usaha kolektif yang melibatkan puluhan ribu
komputer di seluruh dunia.
Sekarang, jom pertimbangkan masalah pengiraan yang berbeza, iaitu masalah mengira pembahagi sepunya terbesar, atau GCD untuk singkatnya,
dua integer bukan negatif.
Ini adalah pernyataan masalah. Input terdiri daripada dua
nombor kali ini, N dan M,
dan kita akan anggap bahawa
ia tidak kedua-duanya sama dengan sifar.
Matlamatnya adalah untuk mengira
GCD dua nombor ini, yang merupakan integer terbesar D yang membahagi dengan sempurna kedua-dua N dan M,
dan kalau kamu fikirkan tentang
pemfaktoran perdana N dan M, apa yang kamu akan temui adalah bahawa GCD adalah hasil darab semua nombor perdana
yang membahagi kedua-dua N dan M dinaikkan kepada minimum kuasa yang muncul dalam dua
pemfaktoran perdana.
Jadi ia berkaitan dengan masalah
pemfaktoran integer, tapi ia ternyata jauh, jauh lebih mudah
untuk komputer selesaikan. Kita boleh mengira GCD untuk nombor dengan beribu-ribu digit
dalam sekelip mata.
Adalah agak tidak berguna untuk saya cuba tunjukkan contoh-contoh pada skrin kerana kita boleh memenuhi
keseluruhan skrin dengan digit dan kita masih menerangkan
kejadian masalah ini yang mudah diselesaikan.
Tapi kalau kamu berminat, ikut pautan dalam penerangan video ke halaman buku teks untuk pelajaran ini dan kamu akan jumpa sel kod
untuk jenis-jenis pengiraan
yang saya bercakap tentangnya, termasuk yang mengira
GCD nombor-nombor besar, dan kamu boleh mencubakannya sendiri.
Soalannya adalah kenapa boleh mengira GCD begitu mudah?
Dan jawapan kepada soalan itu adalah bahawa kita ada algoritma yang cekap
untuk mengira GCD.
Di antaranya adalah algoritma Euclid, yang ditemui lebih 2,000 tahun dahulu, tapi ada juga algoritma GCD
yang cekap lain.
Dan sudah tentu kita bercakap tentang algoritma klasik di sini, jadi itu mengarah kepada soalan lain.
Adakah mungkin ada algoritma klasik yang cekap
untuk pemfaktoran integer
yang akan membolehkan kita memfaktorkan nombor seperti RSA1024
dalam sekelip mata?
Dan jawapannya adalah ya. Sudah tentu boleh ada algoritma klasik yang cekap
untuk pemfaktoran dan buat sekarang kita tidak tahu cara mana pun
untuk menolak kemungkinan itu. Semua yang boleh kita kata adalah bahawa
kita belum menemui satu lagi.
Untuk semua algoritma pemfaktoran klasik yang kita tahu, kita masih pada dasarnya
mencari faktor-faktor
dan itu meletakkan nombor-nombor seperti
RSA1024 di luar kemampuan kita.
Algoritma GCD yang cekap,
sebaliknya, memang tidak berfungsi seperti itu.
Ia tidak mencari
pembahagi sepunya terbesar. Ia berkesan hanya membinanya dengan prosedur mekanikal yang kira-kira setanding dalam kos
dengan mendarab dua nombor yang sama
bersama-sama, dan saya akan berkata sedikit lagi tentang ini kemudian dalam pelajaran.
WEBVTT
Sudah tentu, ini semua membina
kepada algoritma Shor, yang akan kita lihat dalam pelajaran seterusnya, yang merupakan algoritma kuantum yang cekap
untuk mengira pemfaktoran perdana, tapi kita masih ada beberapa perkara
untuk diliputi sebelum kita sampai ke sana.
Seterusnya kita akan bercakap
tentang rangka kerja matematik melalui mana kita boleh mengukur kos pengiraan
algoritma-algoritma yang berbeza,
termasuk yang sudah kita bincangkan.
Untuk jelaskan, kita akan fokus dengan sangat sempit pada circuit, yang hanya sebahagian kecil
daripada subjek yang jauh lebih luas.
Jom mulakan dengan pandangan peringkat tinggi yang sangat tentang pengiraan biasa
dari pelajaran sebelumnya, bermaksud khususnya bahawa kita tidak berfikir
tentang masalah pertanyaan,
kita berfikir tentang
masalah di mana input diberikan secara eksplisit sebagai rentetan binari.
Seperti yang saya kata dalam pelajaran sebelumnya, kita sudah tentu boleh membenarkan
simbol-simbol lain kalau kita memilih, tapi jom hanya simpan mudah dan kekal dengan rentetan binari
untuk kedua-dua input dan output.
Pengiraan itu sendiri boleh dimodelkan atau diterangkan dalam pelbagai cara seperti dengan model pengiraan mesin Turing,
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit, atau program yang ditulis dalam
bahasa seperti Python atau mana-mana bahasa pilihan kamu.
Seperti yang saya kata sebentar tadi, kita akan fokus pada
circuit, Boolean dan kuantum.
Pertama, jom luangkan sedikit masa lagi bercakap tentang input dan output, yang kita anggap adalah rentetan binari.
Menggunakan rentetan binari, kita boleh mengekod banyak jenis
objek matematik yang berbeza, seperti nombor, vektor,
matriks, graf,
penerangan molekul, sebagai contoh, serta senarai semua objek-objek ini dan yang-yang lain juga.
Sebagai contoh yang sangat mudah, kalau kita nak mengekod integer bukan negatif
sebagai rentetan binari, kita boleh guna notasi binari.
Di sini dalam jadual ini, kamu akan nampak 13 pertama
integer bukan negatif bersama-sama dengan perwakilan atau pengekodan binari mereka.
Di sini dalam lajur ketiga, kamu boleh lihat panjang
setiap pengekodan ini, yang hanyalah jumlah bit yang kamu perlukan untuk pengekodan,
dan ini adalah formula mudah yang memberitahu kamu tepat berapa banyak bit
diperlukan secara umum untuk mana-mana integer bukan negatif N.
Perhatikan khususnya bahawa
panjang pengekodan pada umumnya jauh lebih kecil
daripada nombor itu sendiri.
Ia adalah logaritmik dalam nombor.
RSA1024 sebagai contoh, mempunyai pengekodan dengan panjang 1,024, tapi nombor itu sendiri sudah tentu
jauh lebih besar dari itu.
Skema pengekodan ini berfungsi
untuk integer bukan negatif, tapi kalau kita nak menangani
integer sewenang-wenangnya, termasuk yang negatif, kita
boleh hanya menambah bit tanda.
Kita juga boleh membenarkan sebarang bilangan sifar pendahuluan dalam pengekodan ini kalau kita mahu pengekodan
mengisi blok bit atau daftar bersaiz tetap
selagi ia cukup besar. Kadang-kadang itu sangat mudah.
Ini bukan satu-satunya cara untuk mengekod integer sebagai rentetan bit.
Ada cara-cara lain yang boleh kamu lakukan, tapi ini adalah cara yang agak
standard untuk melakukannya.
Untuk jenis-jenis objek lain yang mungkin membentuk input atau output kepada masalah pengiraan yang kita minati, kita boleh mengemukakan
skema pengekodan lain.
Sebagai contoh, fikirkan tentang macam mana
kamu mungkin mengekod vektor atau graf sebagai rentetan binari atau fikirkan tentang macam mana kamu mungkin mengekod
dua rentetan binari ke dalam
satu rentetan binari tunggal menggunakan hanya simbol sifar dan satu tanpa ruang atau simbol lain
untuk memisahkan dua rentetan. Sudah tentu ada cara untuk
melakukan perkara-perkara ini, dan sebenarnya, kita ada banyak kebebasan
tentang cara tepat kita melakukannya.
Selalunya tidak akan ada satu cara standard atau yang disepakati secara universal untuk mengekod apa jua perkara yang kita bercakap
tentangnya sebagai rentetan binari,
tapi itu okay, kita boleh hanya pilih satu atau kita boleh cipta satu baru kalau kita lebih suka.
Dari sudut pandang formal semata-mata, kita fikirkan tentang pengiraan sebagai pada dasarnya transformasi mekanikal pada rentetan bit
dan butiran apa jua
skema pengekodan yang kita guna adalah sudah tentu penting pada sesuatu tahap.
Tapi bagaimanapun, bila kita mereka bentuk dan
menganalisis algoritma, kita biasanya tidak terlalu risau tentang butiran spesifik
skema pengekodan.
Kalau kamu minta dua orang yang berbeza untuk mengemukakan cara untuk mengekod, katakanlah, molekul-molekul jenis tertentu sebagai rentetan binari,
kamu mungkin menjangkakan mereka mengemukakan cara yang berbeza untuk melakukannya, tapi kalau ini adalah orang yang munasabah yang tahu apa yang mereka buat,
kamu juga boleh menjangkakan dengan munasabah bahawa ia akan menjadi proses pengiraan yang agak
mudah untuk menterjemah ke belakang dan ke hadapan antara dua skema pengekodan,
paling mungkin memerlukan pengiraan yang sangat
mudah yang akan agak mudah berbanding dengan pengiraan sebenar
yang kita minati.
Kesimpulannya adalah bahawa butiran mengenai skema pengekodan yang kita guna selalunya agak sekunder dan fokus kita adalah pada
algoritma itu sendiri.
Tiada perkara ini akan menjadi isu untuk pelajaran ini, by the way. Kita terutamanya akan fokus pada masalah yang berkaitan dengan integer, yang kita anggap dikodkan dalam binari,
tapi ia adalah sesuatu yang perlu disedari.
Secara umum, untuk apa jua jenis masalah yang kita bincangkan, panjang input merujuk
kepada bilangan bit yang kita perlukan untuk mengekod input,
dan kita anggap panjang input sebagai saiz kejadian apa jua masalah yang kita fikirkan.
Sekarang, jom pertimbangkan
pengiraan itu sendiri, yang diwakili oleh
segi empat tepat biru dalam rajah ini.
Cara kita akan mengukur
kos pengiraan ini adalah dengan mengira bilangan operasi asas yang ia perlukan.
Secara intuitif, operasi asas adalah yang melibatkan bilangan bit atau qubit kecil dan tetap
yang boleh dilakukan dengan cepat dan mudah seperti mengira dan
dua bit, sebagai contoh.
WEBVTT
Pada tahap formal,
ada cara-cara berbeza untuk mentakrifkan apakah operasi asas itu, bergantung kepada apa
model pengiraan yang kita guna.
Sebagai contoh, operasi asas boleh menjadi satu langkah mesin Turing kalau kita menggunakan model itu.
Untuk tujuan pelajaran ini, kita akan fokus pada model circuit, seperti yang saya dah nyatakan, dan khususnya quantum
dan Boolean circuit.
Bila kita bekerja dengan circuit, adalah tipikal bahawa kita fikirkan setiap gate sebagai mewakili operasi asas.
Kita dah lihat beberapa quantum gate yang berbeza setakat ini dalam siri,
termasuk gate X, Y dan Z, Hadamard gate, gate S dan T,
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate, dan Fredkin gate.
Kita juga bercakap tentang gate pertanyaan dalam konteks model pertanyaan, tapi kita tidak akan bekerja dalam model pertanyaan dalam pelajaran ini, jadi kita tidak akan risau tentang
gate pertanyaan buat sekarang.
Kita juga nampak bahawa mana-mana operasi unitari pada mana-mana bilangan qubit
boleh dilihat sebagai gate kalau kita nak buat itu.
Untuk tujuan mengukur kos walaupun, itu tidak akan sangat membantu, jadi apa yang kita akan buat adalah kita hanya akan pilih set gate
dan kita akan anggap set itu sebagai set operasi asas kita.
Pertama, kita akan sertakan
gate unitari qubit tunggal yang kamu lihat di sini,
iaitu gate X, Y dan Z,
Hadamard gate dan gate S dan T, serta songsangan
atau transpos konjugat mereka.
Kita sebenarnya tidak memerlukan semua gate ini. Sebaik sahaja kita ada Hadamard dan T gate, kita boleh melaksanakan yang lainnya,
tapi hanya demi kemudahan, kita akan sertakan semua sekali.
Kita juga akan sertakan controlled NOT gate, dan ini akan menjadi satu-satunya
gate berbilang qubit dalam set kita.
Dan akhirnya kita akan sertakan pengukuran asas standard qubit tunggal supaya kita sebenarnya boleh mendapatkan beberapa maklumat klasik
yang keluar dari circuit kita.
Kalau kita fokus hanya pada gate unitari dan lupakan tentang
pengukuran sebentar, kita memperoleh apa yang dipanggil
set gate universal.
Apa yang itu bermaksud adalah bahawa
mana-mana operasi unitari pada mana-mana bilangan qubit boleh
sama ada dilaksanakan dengan tepat
atau sedekat mungkin
dengan quantum circuit yang dibina dari gate-gate ini sahaja.
Dengan kata lain, ini adalah
set gate yang cukup baik sehingga kita boleh membina mana-mana operasi unitari
dari mereka.
Tidak semestinya dengan tepat, tapi kita boleh mendapatkan penghampiran sebaik
yang kita mahu.
Itu mungkin memerlukan banyak gate, dan sebenarnya tidak terlalu sukar untuk memberi sebab bahawa ia mesti memerlukan
banyak gate kadang-kadang,
tapi bagaimanapun, ia sentiasa mungkin.
Bukan perkara mudah untuk membuktikan bahawa ini adalah set gate universal walaupun, dan kita tidak akan bincangkan macam mana
itu dilakukan dalam siri,
tapi ia adalah fakta yang agak terkenal dan sebenarnya ada cara-cara berbeza
yang boleh dibuktikan.
Ada juga set gate lain yang kadang-kadang digunakan
dan bukannya yang ini, seperti Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate, dan S gate sebagai tambahan kepada pengukuran,
tapi ini adalah pilihan yang agak standard.
Jadi secara ringkasnya, inilah
operasi kuantum yang akan kita anggap sebagai asas.
Untuk Boolean circuit,
kita akan anggap empat gate ini sebagai
operasi asas: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate dan FANOUT.
FANOUT, by the way, tidak selalu
dikira sebagai gate, tapi ia akan
penting untuk kita lakukan ini seperti yang akan kita lihat kemudian dalam pelajaran.
Sama seperti yang kita ada untuk
set gate kuantum standard kita, set ini adalah sedikit berlebihan.
Kamu tidak perlu kedua-dua AND dan OR. Kamu boleh membuat salah satu menggunakan yang lain dengan tiga NOT gate,
tapi tidak ada salahnya untuk sertakan kedua-dua sekali dan ia hanya mudah.
Seperti yang mungkin kamu dah tahu, ini adalah set gate universal
untuk pengiraan deterministik, bermaksud bahawa mana-mana fungsi
dari bit kepada bit
boleh dilaksanakan dengan Boolean circuit yang terdiri dari gate dari koleksi ini.
Sekali lagi, sama seperti yang kita
ada untuk quantum circuit, ini tidak bermaksud bahawa setiap fungsi boleh dilaksanakan dengan cekap
oleh Boolean circuit,
dan memang kebanyakan fungsi
hanya boleh dilaksanakan dengan circuit yang sangat besar
atas sebab mudah bahawa ada banyak sekali fungsi
dan ia tidak semua boleh mempunyai circuit yang kecil. Hanya tidak ada cukup
circuit kecil untuk diagihkan.
Universaliti adalah lebih mudah
untuk dibuktikan dalam kes ini berbanding kes kuantum seperti yang ternyata.
Jadi kalau kamu belum tahu
cara untuk membuktikannya, fikirkan tentangnya dan
lihat kalau kamu boleh memikirkannya kalau kamu berminat.
Sekarang bahawa kita dah memutuskan tentang
gate yang kita akan benarkan dan kita akan anggap
sebagai operasi asas, kita boleh fikirkan tentang berapa banyak daripadanya
diperlukan untuk melakukan
pelbagai pengiraan.
Untuk melakukan itu, kita akan menggunakan
definisi ini untuk saiz circuit.
Definisi ini berfungsi untuk kedua-dua
Boolean dan quantum circuit dan ia adalah sangat mudah.
Saiz circuit adalah
jumlah gate yang ada padanya.
Sebagai contoh, kalau kita kembali
kepada contoh yang sama yang kita lihat beberapa kali, iaitu Boolean circuit kita untuk mengira XOR eksklusif dua bit,
kita nampak bahawa ia mempunyai saiz tujuh
kerana ada tujuh gate, dua FANOUT gate, dua NOT gate,
dua AND gate dan satu OR gate. Kalau kita memutuskan untuk tidak mengira
FANOUT gate, yang adalah biasa, ia akan mempunyai saiz sama dengan lima,
tapi kita akan mengira FANOUT gate, jadi saiznya adalah tujuh.
WEBVTT
Saiz circuit
sepadan dengan bilangan operasi asas
yang perlu kita lakukan.
Jadi kalau kita melakukan
operasi-operasi itu secara berturutan dan saiz akan memberitahu
kita berapa lama ia akan mengambil,
jadi kamu boleh fikirkan tentang saiz circuit sebagai mewakili masa jalan berurutan.
Ini akan menjadi cara kita
mengukur kos pengiraan untuk tujuan pelajaran ini.
Ada sifat lain
circuit walaupun yang juga boleh dilihat sebagai jumlah masa
yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan circuit, dan itu adalah kedalaman circuit.
Untuk lebih tepat, kedalaman
adalah bilangan gate maksimum yang ditemui pada mana-mana laluan dari wayar input ke wayar output,
yang sama dengan bilangan lapisan gate yang perlu kita buat circuit, di mana lapisan merujuk kepada sekumpulan gate
yang boleh dilakukan secara serentak kerana ia tidak mempunyai
wayar yang sama.
Sebagai contoh, circuit kita
dari sebelumnya mempunyai kedalaman empat, dan kita boleh lihat secara langsung dari rajah bahawa ada empat lapisan.
FANOUT gate boleh
dilakukan secara serentak, NOT gate boleh dilakukan secara serentak dan AND gate boleh juga
dilakukan secara serentak.
Jadi kita boleh fikirkan tentang kedalaman circuit sebagai mewakili masa jalan selari.
Kedalaman circuit adalah sudah tentu konsep yang menarik dan penting dan ada beberapa teknik yang sangat
canggih yang boleh digunakan untuk mengurangkan
kedalaman yang diperlukan untuk sesetengah pengiraan, kadang-kadang agak dramatik, sebenarnya, tapi ia adalah topik yang lanjutan
dan kita tidak akan ada banyak lagi untuk dikatakan tentangnya dalam siri ini.
Jadi sekali lagi, kita akan
mengukur kos pengiraan dari segi saiz circuit atau dengan kata lain,
bilangan operasi asas yang diperlukan untuk melakukan pengiraan.
Pada awal pelajaran, kita bercakap tentang masalah
pemfaktoran integer dan kita nampak bahawa masa yang diperlukan untuk algoritma menyelesaikan masalah ini
boleh meningkat apabila input bertambah panjang, dan ini adalah biasanya
isu yang kita fokus pada
bila kita menganalisis algoritma.
Iaitu, kita berminat dalam cara kos menjalankan algoritma berskala apabila input semakin besar dan besar.
Sudah tentu, jenis penskalaan ini bukan satu-satunya perkara yang penting.
Sebagai contoh, kita mungkin hanya berminat untuk mencari faktor-faktor
RSA1024 dan itu sahaja.
Jadi dalam kes seperti itu, kita bercakap tentang
kejadian masalah tunggal di mana tiada apa pun yang sedang berkembang.
Tapi bila kita berfikir tentang algoritma, cara kos mereka
berskala sangat penting dan ia memberitahu kita banyak
tentang algoritma.
Sudut pandang ini adalah
konsisten dengan idea bahawa algoritma adalah asas, dan seperti yang saya bincangkan sebelum ini,
apabila masa berlalu dan teknologi berkembang, ia akan digunakan terhadap
input yang semakin besar dan besar.
Tapi perhatikan bahawa sementara input kepada masalah pengiraan
boleh bertambah dalam saiz, circuit tidak berkembang.
Setiap circuit mempunyai saiz tetap.
Dan atas sebab itu, kalau kita nak menerangkan
algoritma menggunakan circuit, kita sebenarnya akan perlu sekumpulan circuit untuk melakukan itu,
dan dengan sekumpulan circuit, kita maksudkan koleksi circuit yang semakin besar dan besar supaya kita boleh menampung input
apabila ia semakin besar dan besar. Sebagai contoh, jom pertimbangkan algoritma deterministik klasik
untuk masalah pemfaktoran integer, mungkin satu berdasarkan pembahagian percubaan, tapi butiran spesifiknya tidak benar-benar penting
demi contoh ini.
Kita boleh secara prinsipnya
menerangkan algoritma sedemikian menggunakan sekumpulan Boolean circuit di mana kalau kita nak memfaktorkan nombor
yang perwakilan binarinya mempunyai N bit, kita ambil circuit CN dari keluarga kita dan kita masukkan nombor
yang kita nak faktorkan
ke dalam bit input circuit itu.
Kadang-kadang kita mungkin memilih untuk memparameterkan circuit-circuit ini
dalam cara yang berbeza, jadi mungkin tidak sentiasa berlaku bahawa circuit Nth mempunyai N bit input,
tapi itu adalah cara yang agak tipikal untuk melakukannya. Secara semula jadi, apabila panjang input semakin panjang, kita akan jangkakan circuit
dalam keluarga ini semakin besar
mencerminkan fakta bahawa
memfaktorkan nombor empat bit adalah jauh lebih mudah daripada memfaktorkan nombor 1,024 bit, sebagai contoh.
Dan jadi, dengan itu dalam fikiran, kita mengukur kos algoritma seperti itu dengan fungsi, yang memberitahu kita berapa banyak
operasi asas
yang kita perlukan untuk setiap panjang input yang mungkin, dan kita boleh melakukan ini untuk kedua-dua algoritma klasik dan kuantum.
Sebagai contoh, jom pertimbangkan masalah penambahan integer, yang sudah tentu jauh
lebih mudah daripada pemfaktoran
atau bahkan mengira GCD.
Hanya untuk memudahkan, jom anggap bahawa kedua-dua N dan
M adalah integer bukan negatif dan bahawa ia diwakili
oleh rentetan binari yang mempunyai panjang yang sama.
Macam mana kita mungkin membina Boolean circuit yang menambah dua nombor ini bersama-sama?
Eh, jom mulakan dengan algoritma, algoritma standard untuk penambahan, yang adalah analog asas dua kaedah
yang saya anggap kita semua belajar untuk menambah nombor bersama-sama dengan
pensel dan sekeping kertas, jadi kita mulakan dengan
bit paling kurang penting,
menambahnya bersama-sama, dan itu memberi kita bit paling kurang penting hasilnya bersama-sama dengan bit bawa
yang perlu kita pertimbangkan
bila kita bergerak ke kedudukan seterusnya. Dan kita terus bergerak melalui bit, menjana bit output
bersama-sama dengan bit bawa
sehingga kita sampai ke penghujung.
WEBVTT
Kaedah ini boleh
dinyatakan secara langsung dari segi Boolean circuit.
Salah satu cara untuk memikirkannya adalah dengan mulakan dengan circuit kecil untuk menambah dua integer satu bit bersama-sama.
Itu akan memberi kita nombor
antara sifar dan dua, di mana bit paling kurang penting adalah XOR bit-bit input
dan bit lebih penting, atau bit bawa kalau kamu suka, adalah AND dua bit input.
Kadang-kadang kita merujuk kepada circuit yang melakukan dua
operasi ini bersama-sama sebagai penambah separuh.
Itu berfungsi dengan baik bila
hanya ada dua bit input, tapi kalau kita nak menambah integer dengan lebih daripada satu bit setiap satu,
kita akan perlu menangani
bit-bit bawa entah bagaimana.
Jadi apa yang boleh kita buat adalah dengan menjajari
dua penambah separuh bersama-sama dan mengambil OR bagi
bit bawa yang mereka hasilkan untuk membuat apa yang dipanggil penambah penuh,
yang pada dasarnya adalah Boolean circuit untuk menambah tiga
nombor satu bit bersama-sama.
Dan setelah kita ada penambah penuh, kita boleh menambah nombor bersama-sama
hanya dengan menjajari, bergerak dari bit paling kurang penting
kepada bit paling penting. Kita pada dasarnya hanya melaksanakan algoritma penambahan standard menggunakan penambah penuh untuk
menangani bit-bit bawa.
Jadi berapakah kos pengiraan ini?
Eh, kita perlu tujuh gate asas
untuk setiap XOR gate, yang bermaksud 10 gate untuk penambah separuh
dan oleh itu 21 gate untuk penambah penuh, yang merupakan dua penambah separuh ditambah satu OR gate.
Jadi pada akhirnya, kalau nombor input kita kedua-duanya mempunyai AND bit, kita perlu penambah separuh untuk
bit paling kurang penting
dan penambah penuh untuk setiap bit lain, dan hasil akhirnya adalah 21 kali N tolak satu tambah 10 atau 21 N tolak 11 gate jumlahnya.
Kalau kita memutuskan atas beberapa sebab bahawa kita tidak mahu
mengira FANOUT gate dan kita sertakan XOR
gate dalam set gate kita, kita perlu lima N tolak
tiga gate jumlahnya.
Adalah bagus untuk tahu tepat berapa banyak gate atau operasi asas diperlukan untuk melakukan pengiraan yang berbeza,
seperti yang baru kita lihat dengan penambahan integer.
Dan sudah tentu, kalau kita sebenarnya nak melaksanakan pengiraan-pengiraan ini, kita perlu tahu butiran ini.
Tapi kalau kita sentiasa pergi ke dalam butiran yang begitu banyak, terutamanya untuk
algoritma yang lebih rumit, kita akan dengan cepat terkebumi dalam butiran
yang dalam banyak kes mempunyai
kepentingan sekunder.
Salah satu cara untuk memudahkan perkara yang sangat biasa dalam
analisis algoritma adalah menggunakan notasi big-O,
yang membolehkan kita menyatakan
dan membandingkan kadar pertumbuhan dengan cara yang agak mudah
yang sangat mudah.
Dan di sini kamu boleh lihat definisi yang mendasari notasi ini.
Anggaplah kita ada
dua fungsi G dan H, yang boleh kita fikirkan sebagai mengambil nilai integer bukan negatif untuk kemudahan,
walaupun itu sebenarnya tidak diperlukan. Mungkin G dan H mewakili kos pengiraan yang berbeza, sebagai contoh.
Kita kemudian kata bahawa G adalah big-O dari H, yang secara tradisinya ditulis
dengan tanda sama seperti ini.
Kalau G dari N adalah paling banyak beberapa
pemalar positif C kali H dari N, selagi N cukup besar.
Jadi ini adalah tentang apa
yang berlaku bila N bertambah besar.
Secara formal, apa yang cukup besar bermaksud adalah bahawa ada beberapa pilihan N sifar supaya ketaksamaan adalah benar
bila sahaja N adalah sekurang-kurangnya N sifar.
Kunci di sini adalah bahawa
nombor-nombor C dan N sifar ini adalah tetap.
Ia boleh menjadi mana-mana nombor pun, tapi apa pun ia, ia tidak boleh berubah apabila N bertambah.
Kalau kamu tidak pernah melihat
jenis definisi ini sebelum ini, ia mungkin mengambil masa untuk terbiasa dan kamu boleh menemui sumber
yang akan menerangkan konsep ini
dengan lebih terperinci
daripada yang saya dapat dalam pelajaran ini.
Biasanya apa yang kita buat adalah memilih
fungsi H untuk menjadi mudah untuk menyatakan sesuatu tentang seberapa cepat fungsi G bertumbuh.
Sebagai contoh, fungsi yang nilainya adalah 17 kali N kubus tolak 257
kali N kuasa dua tambah
65,537 adalah big-O dari N kubus, dan kamu boleh masukkan contoh ini ke definisi
dengan memilih C dan N sifar dengan sesuai.
Sebagai contoh, kalau kita ambil C menjadi 18, maka kita akan ada bahawa
ungkapan itu memang paling banyak 18 kali N kubus
selagi N cukup besar.
Mengaitkan notasi ini kembali ke
contoh penambahan integer, apa yang kita kini boleh katakan adalah bahawa ada sekumpulan Boolean circuit
untuk menambah integer bukan negatif bersama-sama supaya saiz circuit ke-N, bermaksud yang berfungsi
untuk input panjang N
adalah big-O dari N. Saiz sebenar CN
mengikut analisis kita adalah 21 kali N tolak 11,
tapi itu adalah big-O dari N.
Sekarang bukan selalu perkara yang bijak untuk membuang butiran seperti ini, tapi di sini ia masuk akal
kerana ia mendedahkan sifat penting algoritma penambahan standard, yang adalah bahawa kosnya berskala secara linear
dalam saiz nombor
yang kita tambah bersama-sama, dan ungkapan ini tidak sensitif kepada beberapa butiran peringkat rendah model kita,
seperti tepat gate mana yang kita anggap sebagai operasi asas.
Sebagai contoh, kalau kita memutuskan bahawa XOR gate harus dianggap sebagai
operasi asas atau bahawa FANOUT gate tidak patut
dikira sebagai gate atau kedua-duanya,
kita masih akan ada bahawa penambahan integer boleh dikira pada kos big-O dari N.
WEBVTT
Ini adalah satu lagi contoh
masalah pengiraan, pendaraban integer.
Sama seperti penambahan, kita boleh tanya apakah kos
pengiraan ini.
Kalau kita pertimbangkan algoritma pendaraban standard, bermaksud analog asas dua kaedah untuk mendarab nombor
yang diajar di sekolah rendah,
yang pada dasarnya hanyalah
peralihan dan penambahan bila kita bekerja dengan nombor dalam binari, kita dapati bahawa ada Boolean circuit yang bersaiz big-O dari N kuasa dua
untuk mendarab integer N bit.
Saya tidak akan melalui yang ini secara terperinci. Sudah tentu circuit-circuit adalah
sedikit lebih rumit daripada yang untuk penambahan, tapi kalau kamu fikirkan tentang cara
algoritma pendaraban standard
berfungsi, ia tidak seharusnya mengejutkan.
Pada dasarnya, kita perlu
melakukan kira-kira N penambahan, setiap yang mempunyai kos linear, dan jadi kita berakhir dengan
kos kuadratik keseluruhannya.
Ini boleh digeneralisasi. Kalau salah satu nombor mempunyai N bit dan yang lain mempunyai N bit, maka kita perlu circuit bersaiz
big-O dari N kali M.
Di sini, by the way, kita sebenarnya menggunakan sambungan notasi big-O di mana kita ada pelbagai pembolehubah, tapi ia boleh dilanjutkan seperti ini,
dan kalau kamu berminat
dalam butiran spesifik, saya akan rujuk kamu ke kandungan buku teks
untuk pelajaran, yang sekali lagi dipautkan dalam
penerangan video.
Sebenarnya mungkin
untuk mendarab dua integer N bit dengan cara
yang secara asimptotik lebih baik daripada algoritma pendaraban standard.
Khususnya, algoritma pendaraban Schonhage-Strassen
mendarab dua integer N bit dengan kos big-O dari
N kali panjang N
kali panjang panjang N. Jadi apabila N bertambah besar, seperti
puluhan ribu bit,
ini sebenarnya adalah cara yang lebih
cekap untuk mendarab, tapi ia adalah rumit dan overhed memang menjadikannya tidak praktikal
untuk nombor-nombor kecil.
Jadi jom tambahkan pendaraban
ke senarai contoh kita.
Dan hanya untuk kemudahan, jom senaraikan kos yang diberikan oleh algoritma pendaraban standard, yang adalah big-O dari N kuasa dua.
Jadi sekali lagi, kita fokus pada sifat penting kos ini, yang adalah bahawa ia berskala secara kuadratik
atau sub kuadratik kalau kita guna kaedah yang secara asimptotik lebih baik.
Kita juga boleh pertimbangkan
masalah pembahagian integer, yang dinyatakan dengan tepat pada skrin.
Di sini kita bercakap tentang mengira hasil bagi dan baki, jadi jawapan terdiri
daripada dua integer, Q dan R.
Sekali lagi, ada algoritma standard
untuk pembahagian dan ia juga mempunyai kos kuadratik dan seperti pendaraban,
sebenarnya ada
algoritma yang secara asimptotik lebih baik.
Jadi macam mana perbandingan kos algoritma GCD?
Eh, algoritma Euclid ternyata
mempunyai kos kuadratik, dan itulah yang saya maksudkan
lebih awal dalam pelajaran bila saya kata bahawa kita boleh mengira GCD
pada kos yang lebih kurang sama dengan mendarab dua nombor bersama-sama.
Sekali lagi, ada
algoritma yang secara asimptotik lebih baik sepanjang garis yang serupa dengan
penambahan dan pendaraban,
walaupun kosnya adalah sedikit
lebih tinggi dalam kes ini, sekurang-kurangnya setakat yang kita tahu.
Saya akan sebut hanya satu lagi contoh masalah untuk ditambah ke senarai ini, dan itu adalah pemangkinan modular.
Di sini ada tiga nombor
input, K, M, dan N, dan matlamatnya adalah untuk mengira
N kepada kuasa K modulo-M,
yang bermaksud baki
selepas kita bahagi dengan M.
Ia tidak jelas sama sekali, tapi kita boleh mengira pemangkinan modular pada kos qubit, bermaksud big-O dari N kubus
untuk integer N bit.
Cara untuk melakukan yang ini bukan dengan pertama mengira N kepada kuasa K dan kemudian mengira bakinya.
Bahkan menulis N kepada kuasa K boleh memerlukan banyak bit secara eksponen, jadi pendekatan itu tidak akan berfungsi.
Sebaliknya, kita boleh guna algoritma
yang dipanggil algoritma kuasa, yang juga dipanggil pengkuasaan berulang di mana semuanya dilakukan modulo-M
dan kita guna bit-bit
K untuk mengkuasadua dan mendarab secara iteratif dengan cara
yang menjadikan semuanya berfungsi.
Jadi yang ini lebih
mahal daripada yang-yang lain, tapi kita masih boleh melakukan
pemangkinan modular dengan agak cepat pada nombor
dengan beribu-ribu bit.
Jadi macam mana perbandingan kos tugas-tugas ini dengan pemfaktoran integer?
Kalau kita mulakan mudah dan
fikirkan tentang pembahagian percubaan di mana kita pertama periksa untuk lihat kalau dua adalah faktor nombor input
dan kemudian periksa tiga dan seterusnya, kita akan berakhir dengan algoritma yang agak
mahal, big-O dari N kuasa dua kali
dua kepada kuasa N atas dua.
Setiap pembahagian mengambil masa kuadratik dan dalam kes terburuk, kita perlu mencari faktor perdana sehingga punca kuasa dua nombor input,
dan dari situ N
atas dua datang. Kalau kita belum menemui
faktor perdana pada ketika itu, kita boleh henti kerana kemudian
nombor input itu sendiri mesti perdana.
Ini sangat mahal kerana N muncul sebagai eksponen dalam ungkapan ini, yang bermaksud bahawa
algoritma ini mempunyai kos eksponen.
Sebaliknya, semua contoh yang kita ada dalam kotak ini di sini mempunyai apa yang kita panggil kos polinomial di mana N dinaikkan kepada kuasa,
tapi kuasa itu sentiasa nombor tetap yang tidak bertumbuh apabila
panjang input bertumbuh.
Dalam kes-kes ini, kuasa-kuasanya
adalah satu, dua, dan tiga.
Saya akan kembali kepada polinomial berbanding kos eksponen dalam sebentar, tapi pertama, jom selesaikan
apa yang kita tahu tentang pemfaktoran.
WEBVTT
Tadi saya menyebut
penapis medan nombor, yang merupakan algoritma pemfaktoran terbaik yang kita ada dari segi cara kosnya berskala.
Sebenarnya, kos algoritma ini tidak dibuktikan dengan ketat kerana ia berkaitan dengan beberapa soalan terbuka tentang teori nombor,
tapi ia diandaikan mempunyai
kos yang kelihatan seperti ini.
Kali ini big-O berada dalam eksponen, tapi saya akan abaikan
butiran itu.
Pengajaran utamanya adalah bahawa ia adalah jauh lebih baik
daripada pembahagian percubaan kerana walaupun N memang
muncul dalam eksponen,
ia dinaikkan kepada kuasa 1/3 dan itu diterjemahkan kepada kos yang jauh lebih rendah dan itulah kenapa algoritma ini
boleh menangani nombor-nombor seperti RSA250, sedangkan pembahagian percubaan
memang tidak boleh.
Ia masih eksponen walaupun dalam erti kata bahawa kuasa N muncul dalam eksponen, dan jadi, sebagai akibatnya,
ia masih tidak boleh menangani
nombor-nombor seperti RSA1024.
Sekarang izinkan saya berkata sedikit lagi tentang kos polinomial
berbanding kos eksponen.
Kita kata bahawa algoritma
mempunyai kos polinomial kalau kosnya adalah big-O dari N kepada kuasa B,
di mana B boleh menjadi mana-mana nombor positif, tapi kunci adalah bahawa B mestilah tetap, bermaksud ia tidak berubah
apabila panjang input N bertumbuh.
Untuk contoh-contoh yang kita lihat sebentar tadi, bermaksud penambahan integer, pendaraban, pembahagian, mengira GCD
dan pemangkinan modular,
kita ada bahawa B adalah sama ada
satu, dua atau tiga.
Jadi ini semua adalah
algoritma kos polinomial.
Tapi bila kita kata kos polinomial
secara lebih umum, B boleh menjadi mana-mana nombor positif.
Ia boleh bahkan menjadi satu juta,
tapi ia mestilah tetap.
Sebagai abstraksi yang sangat kasar, algoritma yang mempunyai kos polinomial pada umumnya dilihat sebagai mewakili algoritma yang cekap.
Ia adalah penyederhanaan melampau tanpa diragui, tapi sebagai garis panduan kasar, kamu boleh fikirkan tentang algoritma kos polinomial
sebagai entah bagaimana menggunakan
struktur masalah untuk membina penyelesaian berbanding dengan jenis pendekatan kekerasan
atau carian menyeluruh
ke atas ruang yang sangat besar.
Sudah tentu, algoritma yang kosnya berskala sebagai N kepada satu juta
pada input panjang N
tidak akan dilihat dengan munasabah
sebagai cekap, dan kita tidak akan jangkakan untuk dapat
menjalankannya pada input yang besar.
Tapi walaupun begitu algoritma N kepada
satu juta mesti melakukan sesuatu yang bijak yang entah bagaimana mencerminkan struktur
apa jua masalah yang ia selesaikan untuk mengelakkan penskalaan eksponen dalam kos yang akan dikaitkan dengan
carian menyeluruh ke atas domain yang besar.
Dan dalam amalan, pengenalpastian algoritma kos polinomial sebenarnya hanyalah langkah pertama
menuju kecekapan.
Kalau masalah adalah penting
dan seseorang menemui algoritma kos polinomial yang pertama
untuk ia, mungkin mempunyai eksponen yang sangat besar,
kamu boleh dengan munasabah pastikan bahawa pereka algoritma
akan menemui penambahbaikan yang menyebabkan eksponen itu turun.
Pada dasarnya, kamu boleh
fikirkan tentang kewujudan algoritma kos polinomial
untuk masalah sebagai menunjukkan kemungkinan menyelesaikan masalah itu
pada input yang cukup besar, tapi masih ada banyak kerja yang diperlukan untuk mencapai kecekapan sebenar.
Dalam teori kerumitan, adalah tipikal untuk mengatakan bahawa kos algoritma
berskala sub-eksponen kalau kos adalah big-O dari dua kepada kuasa N
kepada kuasa epsilon untuk setiap nombor nyata positif epsilon, dan kalau ia tidak sub-eksponen,
maka ia adalah eksponen, atau ia boleh bahkan menjadi super-eksponen seperti dua kepada dua kepada N,
yang adalah dua kali eksponen,
tapi selagi output
tidak terlalu panjang secara super-eksponen, setiap masalah sebenarnya boleh
dikira oleh Boolean circuit
yang mempunyai kos eksponen seperti yang ternyata. Jadi perbezaan penting di sini adalah antara polinomial
dan kos eksponen.
Kita tidak tahu sebarang algoritma klasik kos sub-eksponen untuk
pemfaktoran integer.
Sebagai contoh, kos penapis medan nombor bukanlah big-O dari dua kepada
N kepada epsilon bila epsilon adalah 1/3 atau kurang,
jadi ia tidak memenuhi definisi ini.
Ia tidak diragui algoritma yang sangat bijak, tapi ia masih penapis dan kita masih berkesan mencari
ke atas ruang yang sangat besar untuk mengenalpasti faktor-faktor nombor yang diberikan.
Seperti yang akan kita lihat dalam pelajaran seterusnya, sebenarnya ada algoritma kuantum kos polinomial
untuk pemfaktoran integer.
Algoritma Shor mempunyai kos polinomial dan khususnya ia mempunyai kos qubit, sama seperti pemangkinan modular.
Kelas masalah lain yang
mungkin kamu biasa adalah kelas masalah NP-complete.
Saya tidak akan masuk ke apa masalah NP-complete dalam pelajaran ini, tapi kamu boleh mencarinya
kalau kamu berminat.
Diandaikan bahawa
tiada masalah-masalah ini mempunyai kos sub-eksponen.
Itu pada dasarnya adalah versi berasaskan circuit tentang apa yang kadang-kadang dipanggil hipotesis masa eksponen, tapi setakat ini tiada sesiapa dapat
memikirkan cara untuk membuktikannya.
Sebenarnya, kita bahkan tidak boleh membuktikan bahawa tidak ada algoritma kos linear untuk masalah NP-complete.
Ia memang sangat sukar, sekurang-kurangnya setakat yang kita tahu, untuk menolak kemungkinan
penemuan masa depan algoritma yang luar biasa kreatif
untuk masalah-masalah ini.
WEBVTT
Ini adalah rajah yang
menggambarkan hubungan antara kos polinomial dan eksponen.
Pada paksi X, kita ada panjang input kepada apa jua masalah yang kita fikirkan, dan paksi Y mewakili kos menyelesaikan masalah itu
atau kamu boleh fikirkan tentang
ia sebagai masa yang diperlukan untuk menyelesaikan masalah kalau kamu suka.
Algoritma kos eksponen
mungkin berskala seperti ini.
Untuk input yang pendek, kosnya mungkin tidak terlalu tinggi, seperti memfaktorkan
nombor 12, sebagai contoh,
tapi apabila panjang input semakin panjang, kos pada akhirnya akan meletup.
Algoritma kos polinomial,
sebaliknya, mungkin mempunyai penskalaan yang kelihatan seperti ini.
Kos masih akan meningkat secara umum apabila input semakin panjang, dan ia mungkin bahkan kos lebih daripada algoritma kos eksponen untuk sesetengah input,
tapi pada akhirnya ia akan
jauh lebih murah daripada algoritma kos eksponen dan ia tidak meletup
dengan cara yang melampau yang sama
seperti yang algoritma kos eksponen buat.
Jadi kalau kita bayangkan bahawa kita
ada sesetengah kos maksimum yang kita sanggup belanjakan, atau jumlah masa maksimum yang kita sanggup tunggu untuk jawapan,
kalau kamu lebih suka untuk fikirkan tentang masa, maka algoritma kos eksponen hanya akan berfungsi untuk input
sehingga panjang tertentu,
sedangkan, secara umum, algoritma
kos polinomial akan membolehkan kita menyelesaikan
masalah untuk input yang lebih besar.
Dan itulah kenapa, sebagai contoh, kita boleh dengan mudah mengira GCD untuk nombor dengan beribu-ribu
bit, tapi dalam kes terburuk,
kita tidak boleh memfaktorkan nombor bersaiz ini.
Dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran, kita akan alihkan perhatian kita kepada melaksanakan pengiraan klasik
pada komputer kuantum.
Lebih khusus lagi, kita akan
nampak bahawa mana-mana pengiraan yang boleh dilakukan oleh Boolean circuit juga boleh dilakukan oleh quantum circuit
pada kos yang lebih kurang sama. Lebih-lebih lagi, ini boleh
dilakukan dengan cara yang bersih yang penting kalau kita
nak menjalankan pengiraan-pengiraan ini
sebagai subrutin di dalam
pengiraan kuantum yang lebih besar, dan saya akan terangkan apa yang saya maksudkan dengan bersih bila kita pergi lebih jauh ke dalam perbincangan.
Kita akan menggunakan
Toffoli gate dalam proses ini.
Ingat bahawa Toffoli gate adalah controlled-controlled-NOT gate, jadi tindakan mereka pada keadaan asas standard
adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini pada skrin.
Perhatikan bahawa kita juga boleh
fikirkan tentang Toffoli gate sebagai seperti gate pertanyaan
untuk fungsi AND.
Bukan bermaksud ia adalah gate pertanyaan dalam erti kata yang literal. Seperti yang saya sebut pada permulaan pelajaran, kita tidak bekerja dalam
model pertanyaan pada ketika ini,
tapi sebaliknya, tindakan mereka mengikuti corak yang sama seperti gate pertanyaan.
Kita boleh fikirkan tentang nilai binari A dan B sebagai input kepada fungsi AND dan seperti gate pertanyaan,
nilai-nilai ini digemakan
sebagai sebahagian daripada output dan nilai fungsi, bermaksud AND logik A dan B
di-XOR ke atas qubit bawah. Sekarang, kita tidak sertakan Toffoli gate dalam set gate standard kita.
Kita boleh tukar fikiran kalau kita mahu, tapi kita tidak benar-benar perlu
melakukan itu kerana secara alternatifnya, kita boleh melaksanakan Toffoli
gate menggunakan Hadamard gate,
gate T dan T dagger
dan controlled NOT gate seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Sama sekali tidak jelas
bahawa circuit tertentu ini melaksanakan Toffoli gate, tapi ia memang, dan kamu boleh sama ada percaya kata-kata saya
atau darab semuanya sendiri untuk mendapat latihan tambahan, atau kamu boleh hanya tanya Qiskit atau Python
atau mana-mana perisian yang mendarab matriks untuk melakukan pendaraban untuk kamu.
Dan kamu boleh lihat
kandungan buku teks untuk pelajaran untuk melihat ini dilakukan menggunakan Qiskit.
Sekarang kita boleh teruskan untuk mensimulasikan Boolean gate dengan quantum circuit dan semua yang kita perlukan untuk
melakukan ini adalah NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate dan Toffoli gate.
Operasi-operasi ini semuanya deterministik sebagai tambahan kepada menjadi unitari dan kadang-kadang kita menerangkan
operasi seperti ini sebagai boleh diterbalikkan, dan sebenarnya,
kajian pengiraan boleh diterbalikkan mendahului pengkomputeran kuantum dan dari situ keseluruhan
prosedur ini sebenarnya datang.
Boolean gate yang perlu kita
risaukan adalah NOT gate, Hadamard gate dan FANOUT gate,
Dan apa yang kita akan tunjukkan adalah bahawa kita boleh melaksanakan gate-gate ini, atau mensimulasikannya kalau
kamu suka, menggunakan NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate dan Toffoli gate.
Untuk jelaskan, apa yang
kita mahu adalah quantum circuit yang membolehkan kita mengira nilai-nilai Boolean gate yang baru saya sebut
bila kita berikan qubit dalam
keadaan asas standard sebagai input.
Untuk input keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya, tindakan akan ditentukan
oleh kelinearan seperti biasa.
Kita tidak perlu buat apa-apa
istimewa dengan NOT gate. NOT gate adalah NOT gate dan ia boleh dilaksanakan secara langsung.
Dan OR gate boleh disimulasikan
menggunakan Toffoli dan NOT gate.
AND gate adalah mudah, terutamanya berdasarkan apa yang baru saya kata beberapa ketika tadi tentang Toffoli gate yang pada dasarnya adalah
pelaksanaan gate pertanyaan
fungsi AND.
Untuk lebih tepat, apa yang boleh kita buat adalah memperkenalkan qubit baru yang diinisialisasi kepada keadaan sifar
dan biarkan qubit itu menjadi
sasaran Toffoli gate kita dan biarkan dua qubit input
menjadi kawalan.
Nama-nama berbeza diberikan
kepada qubit tambahan seperti ini, yang sering diperkenalkan
ke dalam pengiraan kuantum dan saya akan panggil ia qubit ruang kerja
hanya untuk memilih nama.
WEBVTT
Andaian tipikal kita pada qubit ruang kerja adalah bahawa ia bermula dalam keadaan sifar dan kita sering boleh mengembalikan
mereka ke keadaan sifar
bila kita selesai dengan mereka, tapi tidak selalu.
Dalam rajah kita ada cat sifar di dalam segi empat tepat bertitik untuk menunjukkan bahawa
permulaan qubit ini
adalah sebahagian daripada proses, dan kalau kamu tidak ada
qubit segar seperti ini, kamu tidak akan dapat
melakukan simulasi ini.
Qubit output bawah
adalah yang kita ambil berat kerana itulah hasil
operasi AND dan kita pada dasarnya dah selesai dengan dua yang lain
jadi ia boleh kekal di dalam kotak.
Sebenarnya, kamu boleh bayangkan bahawa membuang dua qubit ini adalah sebahagian daripada tugas
mensimulasikan AND gate ini,
macam sampah yang
perlu dibersihkan.
Tapi bagaimanapun, begitulah cara kita
boleh mensimulasikan AND gate.
Sekarang bahawa kita tahu cara melakukan AND gate, kita boleh melakukan OR gate menggunakan
salah satu hukum De Morgan.
Kalau kamu letak NOT gate pada dua input dalam output bagi AND
gate, kamu akan dapat OR gate, jadi ia semudah itu.
Dan yang terakhir adalah FANOUT, dan untuk yang ini, semua yang
kita perlukan adalah controlled NOT gate bersama-sama dengan qubit ruang kerja.
Khususnya, kalau kita
tetapkan qubit ruang kerja sebagai sasaran, kita berkesan hanya menyalin apa jua keadaan asas standard yang masuk,
jadi itu bertindak seperti FANOUT gate.
Jadi kita ada semua gate kita.
Dan sekarang bahawa kita ada semua gate kita, kita boleh teruskan kepada circuit.
Jom anggap bahawa kita ada
beberapa Boolean circuit bernama C, dan ini boleh menjadi apa jua
Boolean circuit yang kamu pilih
selagi ia terdiri dari
AND atau NOT dan FANOUT gate.
Kita akan biarkan T menjadi bilangan gate dalam C dan kita akan beri nama F kepada apa jua fungsi yang dikira oleh C.
Jadi kita boleh fikirkan tentang F sebagai mempunyai bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini, di mana N adalah bilangan bit input C,
M adalah bilangan bit output dan sigma adalah abjad binari.
Dan apa yang kita buat adalah hanya pergi satu persatu melalui gate-gate C.
Kita biarkan NOT gate sahaja dan kita gantikan yang lain dengan simulasi
yang baru saya terangkan.
Jadi kalau C kelihatan seperti ini, maka apa yang kita dapat adalah circuit
R yang kelihatan seperti ini.
Dalam rajah ini, semua
qubit ruang kerja yang kita perlukan untuk simulasi telah ditarik keluar dari kotak dan dikumpulkan di bawah.
Jadi K adalah jumlah bilangan
qubit ruang kerja yang kita perlukan, yang adalah satu untuk setiap gate C kecuali NOT gate.
Untuk output R, kita ada qubit yang
sepadan dengan output C, dan di sini qubit-qubit itu
digambarkan di atas,
walaupun ia sebenarnya tidak akan penting pada akhirnya
sama ada ia berada di atas atau tidak.
Untuk lebih tepat, dengan mengandaikan bahawa kita dah menjalankan R pada keadaan asas standard yang sepadan dengan
rentetan N bit sewenang-wenangnya X,
qubit output M ini akan berada dalam keadaan asas standard
yang sepadan dengan F dari X.
Kita juga ada semua qubit sisa dari AND dan OR gate.
Kita masih perlu mengambil kira mereka, dan kalau kita kumpulkan semuanya bersama-sama, ia akan berada dalam beberapa keadaan asas standard.
Apa jua keadaan asas standard itu mestilah beberapa fungsi rentetan X, dan kita akan beri
fungsi itu nama G.
Jadi G adalah fungsi baru yang
ditentukan oleh gate-gate C yang memberitahu kita keadaan apa
qubit-qubit sisa ini
selepas R dijalankan. G adalah huruf seterusnya selepas F, jadi itulah satu sebab untuk
memanggil fungsi ini G,
tapi sebab lain untuk memanggilnya G adalah kerana G adalah singkatan untuk sampah.
Ini semua adalah qubit sampah, dan khususnya, kita
ada dua qubit sampah untuk setiap AND gate dan untuk setiap OR gate.
Jumlah gate
yang kita perlukan adalah big-O dari T.
Itu kerana untuk setiap gate C, kita perlu bilangan gate kuantum yang terhad.
OR gate adalah yang paling mahal. Untuk yang itu, kita perlu tiga NOT gate bersama-sama dengan satu Toffoli gate,
dan Toffoli gate menelan kos 15 gate dari set gate standard kita.
Jadi itu adalah paling banyak 18 gate
dalam R untuk setiap gate C.
Kalau kamu nak mengoptimumkan ini, kamu boleh, tapi untuk tujuan
analisis asimptotik kasar, kita boleh hanya kata bahawa
R mempunyai gate big-O dari T.
Jadi kita berjaya
mengira fungsi yang sama F yang Boolean circuit asal
C kira,
dan kita dah buat ini pada kos yang linear dalam saiz C.
Kalau semua yang kita ambil berat adalah
mengira fungsi F ini, maka kita selesai.
Tapi malangnya, kita memang
ada qubit sampah ini dan qubit sampah ini
pada umumnya akan merosakkan
corak gangguan yang menjadikan algoritma kuantum berfungsi kalau kita cuba menggunakan
circuit R ini sebagai subrutin
di dalam algoritma kuantum yang lebih besar.
Tapi kita sebenarnya boleh
menyingkirkan sampah ini, dan cara kita boleh melakukan
ini adalah menggunakan fakta bahawa circuit R boleh disongsangkan,
WEBVTT
atau dengan kata lain, kita
boleh menjalankannya secara terbalik.
Untuk menggambarkan macam mana ini berfungsi, jom bayangkan bahawa kita pertama menjalankan R dan kemudian kita menjalankan R secara terbalik,
yang boleh kita nyatakan sebagai R dagger.
Untuk jelaskan tentang ini, apa yang itu bermaksud adalah bahawa kita gunakan gate-gate
R dalam urutan terbalik dan kita ambil songsangan
setiap gate.
NOT gate, controlled NOT
gate dan Toffoli gate sebenarnya adalah songsangan sendiri, jadi kalau kita berfikir dari segi
gate-gate ini,
maka R dagger adalah benar-benar hanya R dengan gate-gate dibekalkan
dalam urutan terbalik.
Tapi secara umum, kita sentiasa boleh menjalankan mana-mana quantum circuit unitari secara terbalik dengan cara yang baru saya terangkan,
bermaksud bahawa kita gunakan
gate-gate dalam urutan terbalik dan kita gantikan setiap
gate individu dengan songsangannya.
Kalau kita melakukan ini, kita akan dapati bahawa pertama menjalankan R dan kemudian menjalankan R secara
terbalik tidak melakukan apa-apa langsung.
Jadi kalau kita bermula dalam keadaan asas standard seperti yang kita ada di sini, maka kita akan berakhir dalam keadaan asas standard yang sama persis.
Sudah tentu, hanya melakukan
itu tidak begitu membantu, tapi apa yang boleh kita buat adalah kita boleh perkenalkan beberapa qubit tambahan dan khususnya,
ini adalah qubit M di mana M adalah bilangan bit output circuit C.
Qubit-qubit tambahan ini boleh
berada dalam mana-mana keadaan kuantum, tapi untuk menerangkan macam mana ini berfungsi, kita akan anggap bahawa ia berada dalam keadaan asas standard
yang sepadan dengan beberapa rentetan Y. Jadi Y adalah rentetan M bit, dan apa yang boleh kita buat adalah melakukan
sekumpulan controlled NOT
gate seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, yang berkesan meng-XOR rentetan F dari X
ke atas rentetan Y yang tersimpan
dalam qubit M bawah ini.
Dan jadi output
keseluruhan pengiraan adalah seperti yang terpapar pada skrin.
X dan Y adalah rentetan binari sewenang-wenangnya. X mempunyai bit M dan Y mempunyai bit M, dan kita juga perlu qubit ruang kerja K.
Bila kita menjalankan R, kita kira F dari X dan rentetan itu disimpan
dalam qubit M atas, tapi kita juga ada sekumpulan qubit sampah,
jadi kita XOR output F dari
X ke atas qubit M bawah dan kemudian jalankan R secara terbalik
untuk membersihkan sampah.
Saya patut tunjukkan bahawa adalah penting bahawa R adalah deterministik.
Kalau qubit M atas ini sebaliknya boleh berada dalam beberapa superposisi
keadaan asas standard, ini tidak akan berfungsi dengan betul,
tapi ini memang berfungsi bila
R adalah deterministik.
Jadi kalau kita bandingkan quantum circuit
yang baru kita bina dengan Boolean circuit asal C, kita nampak bahawa ia pada dasarnya
berfungsi dengan cara yang sama
seperti gate pertanyaan berfungsi
untuk fungsi sewenang-wenangnya.
Ada perbezaan di sini, yang adalah bahawa kita perlu
qubit ruang kerja ini untuk menjadikan semuanya berfungsi, tapi sebaliknya kita berkesan telah membina gate pertanyaan
atau circuit pertanyaan untuk apa jua fungsi yang dikira oleh C.
Kita juga berjaya, by the way, untuk mengembalikan qubit
ruang kerja ke keadaan awal mereka, jadi ia boleh secara prinsipnya digunakan semula
sebagai qubit ruang kerja untuk
pengiraan seterusnya.
Kalau kita mahu, kita boleh letak kotak di sekeliling keseluruhan quantum circuit dan panggil ia Q dan hubungan kepada
C menjadi lebih jelas.
Circuit Q akan
lebih besar daripada C secara umum. Kita perlu beberapa gate kuantum dalam Q untuk setiap gate C,
dan kita juga perlu controlled
NOT gate di tengah, tapi bilangannya masih
linear dalam saiz C.
Patut juga dicatatkan bahawa ini adalah prosedur yang sepenuhnya umum yang berfungsi untuk mana-mana Boolean circuit, dan kita tidak cuba langsung untuk mengoptimumkan Q.
Untuk circuit tertentu C, mungkin ada
cara untuk mengurangkan saiz Q, dan itu termasuk menggunakan kaedah
yang mengurangkan bilangan
qubit ruang kerja yang diperlukan sekiranya itu adalah sesuatu
yang kita nak buat, dan itulah prosedur untuk menjalankan
pengiraan klasik
pada komputer kuantum.
Ia agak mudah, tapi ia adalah
perkara yang penting untuk dapat dilakukan.
Khususnya, sekarang bahawa
kita tahu cara melakukan ini, kita bebas untuk menggunakan mana-mana pengiraan klasik yang kita mahu
di dalam pengiraan kuantum, dengan syarat bahawa kita ikut bentuk ini di mana input digemakan dan output di-XOR
ke atas sekumpulan qubit
sama seperti yang kita ada untuk gate pertanyaan.
Kos berskala secara linear. Jadi sebagai contoh, kita boleh
mencipta quantum circuit untuk masalah seperti penambahan integer,
pendaraban, pembahagian, mengira GCD dan pemangkinan modular, dan ini semua boleh dilakukan pada kos asimptotik yang sama
seperti untuk Boolean circuit.
Kita memang perlu qubit ruang kerja untuk melakukan ini, tapi sekurang-kurangnya ia tersedia untuk digunakan semula apabila
kita selesai dengan mereka.
Satu catatan akhir yang berbaloi disebutkan adalah bahawa kaedah ini memberi kita kaedah untuk melaksanakan gate pertanyaan,
yang saya singgung dalam pelajaran sebelumnya.
Iaitu, kalau kita ada algoritma pertanyaan yang mengambil beberapa fungsi F sebagai input, dan kita ada cara untuk mengira
F dengan Boolean circuit,
maka kita boleh ikuti prosedur ini untuk membina gate pertanyaan untuk fungsi itu dan kemudian menjalankan algoritma pertanyaan kita padanya.
Sama ada itu adalah perkara yang berguna untuk dilakukan bergantung pada masalah pertanyaan itu sendiri dan apa yang kita cuba capai, tapi pada dasarnya, pembinaan ini memberi kita
cara untuk menghubungkan model pertanyaan kepada model pengiraan yang lebih standard.
Ini adalah dalam erti kata tertentu cara algoritma Shor untuk pemfaktoran integer berfungsi.
WEBVTT
Kita akan membina
quantum circuit seperti ini dari beberapa operasi aritmetik yang kita bincangkan lebih awal dalam pelajaran.
Dan dengan melakukan itu, kita
memberi quantum circuit keupayaan untuk menilai operasi-operasi tersebut pada superposisi keadaan klasik.
Dan seperti yang akan kita lihat, itu membolehkan kita memfaktorkan integer dengan cekap.
Itulah penghujung pelajaran ini, yang telah fokus terutamanya pada mewujudkan asas
untuk algoritma kuantum dalam rangka kerja pengiraan standard bukan kotak hitam.
Kita bincangkan kos pengiraan terutamanya melalui kanta masalah yang berkaitan dengan teori nombor asas.
Kita bincangkan kos polinomial
berbanding eksponen untuk tugas-tugas pengiraan, dan kita nampak macam mana pengiraan klasik
boleh dilaksanakan oleh quantum circuit dengan cara yang bersih bebas sampah yang membolehkan ia digunakan sebagai subrutin
di dalam pengiraan kuantum yang lebih besar.
Saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk pelajaran seterusnya di mana kita akan nampak macam mana algoritma Shor menggunakan idea-idea ini, membolehkan kita memfaktorkan
integer pada kos polinomial.
Selamat tinggal sehingga ketika itu.